the nature of outriders has put the game
in a bit of a strange position it
combines a traditional third-person
shooter with a story-based rpg and on
top of that it layers a loot shooter
formula that gives you weird goofy
frequently awesome weapons and armor to
chase as you progress through its
campaign when i reviewed outriders at
launch i pointed out that it should be
thought of more as an rpg than the loot
shooter live game it appears to be but
though most of it might feel like an rpg
shooter outriders does have a live
service games end game meant to keep
players busy challenging themselves with
tough content and chasing better and
better loot with the end game comes the
same problem that all live games deal
with the struggle to keep players
engaged developer people can fly is
addressing the end game issue head on
with worldslayer a big outrider's
expansion due in june the expansion
makes major adjustments to character
progression the difficulty tuning
challenge system the loot chase and the
end game reworking a lot about outriders
to make it a game you can sink more time
into and that's to say nothing of the
expansion's new story we played about 90
minutes of worldslayer although that was
entirely too little to actually get a
real sense of the expansion both because
it adds a lot of content and because its
changes will take time for players to
really sift through world slayer starts
with a campaign that continues the story
players wrapped up in the base game of
outriders picking up almost exactly
where it left off while world slayer
assumes you finished the original story
campaign and chase down orbital drop
pods in expeditions outrider's original
endgame activity you don't have to have
done those things to access the new
expansion
you can boost your character up to the
base game's level cap and start the new
content immediately so if you're new to
outriders but have friends who are vets
you can join them in worldslayer without
waiting anyway hunting down those drop
pods has also supplied you with new data
for abraham zahidi the scientist you
recruited to your band of heroes in the
main game and with it he discovers some
new upsetting information the anomaly is
a strange deadly storm that routinely
ravages enoch vaporizing people and
occasionally turning some of them into
god-like superhumans known as the
altered and it's growing in both size
and power if the anomaly keeps growing
it's going to wipe everyone out we
immediately see the threat of those new
storms in an icy level at the expansion
start where the volatile weather was so
powerful flying creatures were freezing
and falling out of the sky not long
after the players group returns to rift
town the primary home of their allies to
find it wrecked by storms as well the
story quickly becomes one of trying to
find a way to do something about the
anomaly after chana another member of
your team experiences a vision of the
future that provides a new lead we
learned a lot about the anomaly and its
origins in the base game of outriders
and with the survival of humanity on the
line there's not much choice but to go
on another road trip across enoch in an
attempt to save the world that's going
to put us at odds with a new big bad a
scary looking altered called areshkogal
who leads the enemy insurgent faction
but who unfortunately didn't pop up
during our playtime the next level we
saw takes the outrider and their team to
an abandoned fishing village as thiago
another teammate provides information
about how we might reach a fortress
controlled by the enemy insurgents after
thiago gives us a little backstory about
the village in the form of a ghost story
about a fisherman with a hook and a
raincoat murdering insurgents we learn
the truth the fisherman isn't a ghost at
all he's a towering insurgent boss and
the empty village is actually the site
of an ambush the fight against the
fisherman and his gang is a top one
mostly because he likes to rush around
the battlefield picking up players so he
can rip into them with that huge hook
but world slayer doesn't drastically
alter outriders moment-to-moment
gameplay so these levels will feel
similar to what players saw in the base
game although you should expect a host
of new enemy types and bosses to freshen
up combat a bit along the way the big
changes coming to the game in the
expansion are actually somewhat more
subtle world slayer's additions are
aimed at giving you more to do over the
long term like the addition of the new
pax progression trees outriders already
included three different skill trees
that allow you to unlock abilities for
your specific character you pick a class
at the outset of the game like
demolisher who controls rocks and
gravity or trickster which is all about
slowing enemies and teleportation and
then use the skill trees to further
specialize with specific abilities or
stat boosts world slayer throws two more
trees at you for each character allowing
you to specialize even further you
unlock skills and upgrades on the pax
trees with their own special pax points
which you earn by progressing through
the world slayer story but maybe the
most interesting and meaningful addition
to outriders overall is the apocalypse
system which upends the end game as it's
been established up until now although
we only saw a brief glimpse of it when
outriders launched it included a system
that let you set the difficulty with
world tiers or challenge tiers world
tiers were settings for the story
campaign that gave you better loot as
you turned up the difficulty challenge
tiers were a set of 15 additional
difficulty tiers that kicked in during
the expeditions activity once the story
was done apocalypse tears
challenge tiers expanding those optional
difficulty tiers from 15 to 40.
apocalypse tiers add a lot of
flexibility in making outriders tougher
and therefore giving you a reason to
keep playing you'll be able to set your
apocalypse tier throughout all outriders
content including the original campaign
and the payoff is in the loot these
tiers let you earn apocalypse guns and
armor which is a new set of amped up
gear that's even better than the best
weapons and armor previously seen in
outriders the big difference is the
addition of a third modification slot to
those weapons on armor in the past all
outrider's gear topped out at two mod
slots which means apocalypse gear is
more customizable and will come with
more unique perks the best part about
riders in the past was its ridiculous
guns and armor with their own special
perks like my personal favorite a
shotgun that causes meteors to fall out
of the sky and hit your target expect
apocalypse loot to add even more weird
awesome elements like that one in
addition to your pax progression there's
also a new ascension character
progression system to go along with the
increased difficulty of the apocalypse
tears ascension kicks in after you've
maxed out your character at level 30 the
previous character peak from the
outriders campaign after 30 you start
earning ascension points that you can
spend for small but stacking boosts in
four areas brutality endurance anomaly
and prowess each of these categories has
five subcategories into which you can
bank points giving you upgrades like
boost to your special attack damage or
your overall health the aim is to
collect all 200 ascension points to
maximize your power across the board but
people can fly says it'll take a huge
time investment to unlock them all
giving you something to chase throughout
worldslayer there's also a new endgame
activity to go with expeditions although
we don't know much about it yet called
trials of tarja guartar it's apparently
completely different from the expedition
missions outriders veterans have already
seen square enix and people can fly say
more information about the endgame
activity is headed our way in the coming
months ahead of the expansion's release
the time i spent playing world slayer
was a good reminder of what i liked
about outriders fast-paced shooter
combat that mixes taking cover and
planning with busting out powerful
ridiculous superpowers and crushing
enemies to recover health the additions
to the overall formula like apocalypse
tears ascension points and pax trees all
sound like significant improvements but
in practice we only got a small sampling
of each of them they're the sorts of
changes that snowball over time starting
off with incremental additions like
buffing weapon damage by a couple of
percentage points and slowly turning
into meaningful ways to sculpt your
playstyle as they pile up the
opportunity to spend more time in the
weird and expansive world of outriders
is a strong draw for worldslayer and all
the new additions make it sound like
people can fly has looked at its game
and tried to identify as ways to enhance
all of it the rpg the story and the loot
shooter end game but we'll have to see
what those changes bring to the game
overall because while a snapshot is
promising it's the whole of worldslayer
that's going to reveal if this expansion
brings the game what it needs to endure
okay
there's someone else here
they're completely frozen